you know there's like a million super
obvious ways for me to open this from
going T or oh great hot or engage or any
of that but you know what I just want to
open by pointing out the fact that
Picard named his dog number one pick
card I didn't know if I was going to do
this it's one of those things that like
I never know if I'm gonna catch these
things at the time that they air like
just trying to get my life in order
don't let me get to them in a timely
fashion and then what I do I don't know
if I'm gonna like them or I mean not
even necessarily like them whether I'm
gonna have somebody just say because
sometimes you know if I don't like
something I have something to say if I
like somebody have something to say the
worst is when things are mediocre which
is why I didn't make a review video off
of the film doolittle it wasn't good but
it wasn't bad in any way that was
actually interesting to talk about but
Picard aired and I do want to talk about
it so first like a little bit about my
own sort of place in Star Trek Star Trek
is something I've always enjoyed but has
never been a top-tier fandom for me I
there is no version of Star Trek that I
have seen everything for I haven't seen
all of the original I haven't seen all
of next-generation even though that's my
favorite one I have seen barely any Deus
9 like maybe three episodes of voyage or
one episode of enterprise I haven't seen
discovery I've seen all the movies that
have come out you know original cast
next-gen and the reboot but that's about
it
so I I am I and I like Star Trek I do
but it's just there it's a commitment to
to try and like really dig into this
stuff and it's then it's not a
commitment I've ever made
and but like I said next generation is
my own personal preferred track
and I mean it's what I is what I grew up
on to the extent that I grew up on on
Star Trek at all basically that and and
Star Trek for the voyage home was Star
Trek for me growing up and I I was kind
of uneasy about this because the trailer
based off the trailer I was a I was
really afraid that we're gonna pull
Logan with Picard and I mean part of
that is the fact that Patrick Stewart
was in Logan as well and that's not a
knock on Logan
I felt Logan was really good but I
didn't want to see that happen to Picard
so I went into this nervous this just
felt good we'll see if it can maintain
sort of a spell that a cast over me but
I loved this I thought this was terrific
I really enjoyed the way that it
reminded me to brought back feelings
that I haven't had towards Star Trek in
a long time it it's scratched nostalgia
without feeling like it was pandering to
nostalgia it it feels like it's moving
forward and like gives us a hint of some
things you know maybe not everything
worked out just the way you want without
tearing it down like your heroes all
know it feels like a reasonable
realistic you know late in life place
that Picard's at and where things are
and it's not even like at least so far
doing the success of like dirtying up of
you know Starfleet isn't what you
thought it was and like there are hints
that some stuff like maybe isn't great
but it doesn't feel like it's trying to
be more mature by tearing down what Star
Trek is because Star Trek a lot of
people point to the optimism of Star
Trek and it does have that but part of
that is because it has a very clear
not particularly gray moral compass not
necessarily the world and all the
characters in it but the show as a whole
has always had that and I didn't want
this to lose it and it doesn't feel like
it has least not an episode in which is
early so we'll see but Patrick Stewart
slips back into this role so well and
it's funny because you know it's been
long enough since he's played this but I
kind of wondered you know how is this
gonna be distinct from anything else
I've you know from Professor Xavier you
know from is it gonna feel like jean-luc
Picard or is it just gonna feel like a
late era Patrick Stewart performance
that could have been anything like nope
nope that's that's John Luke and that's
how good and seen brent Spiner felt good
that worked better than I would that I
would have thought cuz I remember a
couple years ago him saying he didn't
think you would ever play David again
because even under all the makeup you
can tell how he's aged and you can a
little bit but you know they're also
dream sequences because surprisingly I
probably stopped wondering this through
the first half I'm not I won't get into
like major spoilers until a little bit
later if you haven't seen it yet but you
know the the things with data their
dream sequences because I wondered in
the first half of this episode they just
gotta ignore nemesis kind of like the
entirety of the fandom does or they just
gonna leave us to presume that before
did effectively become data are they
just gonna leave it ambiguous like no
nemesis is canon date is dead before was
a thing he could not replace data like
dang alright you know props to that it
it's a funny thing with continuity
because it's very easy for ooh
anything wrong writing to become a slave
to its own
continuity and to basically render
itself unable to do new and interesting
things in the name of maintaining
continuity that's a very easy trap to
fall into but on the other hand you know
there's treating continuity very
lackadaisical II and leg doesn't matter
which is different kind of frustrating
and there's something to be said for a
show that can acknowledge the continuity
from a movie that nobody liked and not
have it feel like it's going like well
that was crap and we're forgetting but
like acknowledge it but not feel like
it's time down the story like know the
fact that data passed away in that story
that's actually something we want to
build from so yes we are going to
acknowledge that I was kind of surprised
that I kind of like that I also liked
some of the other characters that we got
as well I mean I like the dog we had
dodged who's this young woman who had
has sort of a basically she she gets
attacked and then she defends herself
and she doesn't know how and then she
has a vision of Picard and then she goes
looking for him I was surprised how well
I connected to her as quickly as I did
and I think a large part of that is
Patrick Stewart really sold him caring
about her and I think that that's a
really good thing that they pertained
about John Luke he's clearly a bit too
solution we get some some indications of
things haven't gone sour between him and
Starfleet you know so the heat there is
a little bit of that bitterness going on
but as soon as he sees someone in danger
he wants to help and that's I think
that's what I was afraid of I I was
afraid that he was gonna go uh I don't
do that anymore go away you know and
turn away the people came to him for
help and like that's not John Luke but
this show knows that's not
Luke he sees someone who needs help
coming to him saying can you help me and
his immediate thoughts are okay let's
figure this out let me figure out how I
can help ya that's great
umm I liked the the name Audrey I think
was it but the the the synthetics and
robotics scientists that jean-luc speaks
with and she and she showed up in the
this season on Picard thing teaser for
what comes later which means she sticks
around which is great because she had
great chemistry with Patrick Stewart and
I really liked hers yes wonderful
delivery of this line of these lines
really oh the short answers no and the
long answer that's also gonna be no and
then you know later they start having
this conversation this longer thing and
they eventually get to the point where
she's like and now you're headed towards
that no I promised you I'm like oh this
is good this is wonderful this is sweet
this is oh it is updated and modern and
revised but this feels like Trek and I
think it's because it's got that heart
and it's got that spirit of knowing what
the right thing is and doing the best
that you can to attain it and for
remembering that that's who Picard that
the card is an embodiment of the ideals
he is what Starfleet is supposed to be
whether or not they actually are that
thing and I'm so grateful that this show
remember that I'm gonna get a little bit
into spoilers because I'm gonna talk
about some of the stuff that happened at
the very end of the episode or the tail
end
so that's your warning like I'm I don't
think I'm gonna spend a ton of time on
it but you've been warned so I was
surprised how hard it hit me when dodge
died like first of all I didn't expect
it at all and under other circumstances
I might have called the oh she's
actually got a twin sister played by the
same actress and now we got a now it'll
would just be her that we're dealing
with normally I might have called
shenanigans on that like it said that's
kind of cheap but I don't know it worked
and again I think largely because of
Patrick Stewart like the scene the hope
come back in his face like there's a
twin he's like I can still do something
to help I think that helped but also
like I said her die hit me a lot harder
than I expected and again I think that's
combination of the actress doing a
really good job good job of connecting
to the emotional core of the confusion
and the fear and the frustration of this
character and Patrick Stewart absolutely
selling how much he wanted to help and
the impact of her dying hitting him so
between the two of those things that hit
me a lot harder than I expected
so I'm glad that that's that's gonna
continue to move forward and have the
Romulans are in a I'm assuming derelict
Borg cube what ha ha yeah I I don't know
what's going on with that but I'm here
for it I'm genuinely excited about this
now like more so that I was going going
in I was kind of like I hope it's good
now I've seen this first episode I'm
like when's the next one like can I have
it now please like I now I wish I could
be in this friggin thing I don't know if
I'll continue to do episode by episode
reviews that actually that'll probably
be determined by you folks and and how
well this does as the thing but I
absolutely wanted to talk about this
first episode if nothing else it's
really good oh man I I didn't
expected I expected it to be well I
didn't really expect it to be anything
but my highest hopes were that it would
be decent and I expected I'd probably
you know nod off after a few episodes
and I suppose as possible they still
will but I don't see that happening cuz
this opens so strong like this will
carry me through the season I'll be
chasing the high of this first episode
through at least the entirety of this
first season of it and I just I just
hope that that I get more just like it
because as much as Star Trek has not
been one of my top fandoms or one of the
ones I go back to most frequently or
anything I do like it and when I connect
with Trek material it really does
scratch an itch that other stuff just
doesn't and it's been a while since I've
felt that it's scratched properly I
would say it's probably been since
honestly the last episode of next
generation I mean I like first contact
don't get me wrong but it's it's a
different beast it's an action movie and
I actually like reboot track well enough
but again they're more it's more action
it's it doesn't quite scratch that itch
that used to be scratched by episodes of
next generation and movies like the
voyage home and even though this isn't
like directly feeling like it's trying
to be those things specifically it's
Avoca numb so well that it's scratching
that edge that feels good
Picard first episode you seen it what
did you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it if you wish
to help me keep this thing going I have
a
you're on and he's what would be
immensely appreciated but even beyond
that you can like and subscribe which
help me in other ways by waving down the
algorithm going hey people care so
that's appreciated as well so plus
there's links for stuff down below I've
got an Instagram now for the council I
think there's only like five things on
it but it exists you can check that out
other stuff besides or don't yet don't
have to cuz end of the day you're the
council I'm just running the meetings
and until next time this council is
adjourned I should have done the old
grade yeah I got the front I genuinely
like Earl Grey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]